what do you think is the best
martial art to prepare you for street
fighting you know people often kind of
have this discussion of jiu-jitsu maybe
boxing maybe wrestling
do you think when you talk about a young
person studying martial arts to prepare
themselves
for um a street fight it's often
much different than a mixed martial art
fight and
i know there's a lot of bs in the world
of martial art like self defense stuff
that
like but i believe
self-defense is is very important in a
way to understand
the the situation to understand those
those situations that might accurate how
to deal with it
because not necessarily the the
we talk about the technicality we talk
about the tacticality the tactics
you know like when i'm talking to you
about the element of surprise is
important this is not
technique a technique is a punch or or
techniques that i physically will
use to enable my my my opponent
my my aggressor tactic is the tactic i'm
telling you about is in a street fight
if someone is looking for trouble and i
feel the heat rising as the conversation
goes that's the position i'm gonna take
and
i have to be first i cannot let him
go first so i have to strike first or do
something this is the first thing that
generally and i have to to
to agree on um
after that of course there is the the
knowledge if you're a professional
fighter
you have a huge advantage once the fight
is started the war is declared now it's
everything goes but generally speaking
the person that will
intervene physically that will have the
first blower the first
you know the first punch will
have a huge this use advantage it's like
doing a hundred meter race
and having a head start you know and and
that you don't you can't prepare
for with any martial art yeah and and if
i'm a smart guy
i know how to fight if a guy like uh an
heavyweight champion comes to me or
like like like a you know i know i know
what what to do to this
disable him like boom or here and then
or the neck you know like and if you
if you blind them what is it going to do
you know what i mean so so
or a bottle you know what i mean so so
the element of surprise
is it's everything so that's why it's
always
always good to be the nice guy and not
looking for trouble because if you're
not looking for trouble
you have the head start you have the
option of having a head start
so what you're saying is being a nice
guy is the is the best form of
self-defense maybe a little humor
yeah you know i have learned that i've
learned that when i was a kid
yeah i was about maybe seven
six six years old we used to to play in
in montreal is a lot of snow we used to
play king of the mountain
yeah that's the first combat lesson that
i've learned in my life
and i managed somehow it was a lot of
kid i managed to get on the top of the
mountain and uh
another guy came come in on the top of
the mountain and he he was angry that
before i
i was there before him and when you
played king of the
mountain it was a mountain of snow you
don't strike each other we just
wrestle and push and i managed to be
first and when he came
he says to me say okay you wanna you
wanna fight
and i said yeah i don't know what it
means like i wanna fight you wanna
wrestle you say i i say yes
he punched me right in the face boom and
then i
and then i fall on on the bottom of the
mountain but then i when i fall down
i remember that vision in mali because
it it it's it's
i will remember that for the rest of my
life i'm about to stand up
and i see the blood coming out of my
nose see the the snow is red because my
nose is bleeding
now i i remember the element of
surprises
everything my first street fight i've
lost it i got it
i didn't get knocked out but i i got
dropped on the bottom of the
snow mountain and i was like uh he got
me because
i was not expecting my hand i was not
expecting a punch
so from there when i felt the the the
eat
of an in during an argument or something
was not right i always stroke first
i didn't win all my fight because
sometimes there were more than
one guys on on me you know but
i think it's important to not be the
aggressor so you have the element of
surprise
and i always use that in your favor
that's so brilliant
you